[Music]
very girlfriends
it's always been you know that
brotherhood between us the first it will
always be tinted brother would always be
dear but I'm trying to win the east
front man we should hang out all day but
where they come together game time I put
on a win he's from the way and we
competitor that ended a spitball his
good
we said we're friends on the corn on the
machine 35 points LeBron James inside
we've got a star-studded game out on the
court among these great high school
talents the Express would hype it has
started two years ago I learned that
benefit but this game's gonna get more
physical as I move on in my career
what's your long time yet to get you in
there
every day you gotta go out there work
there's someone out there working too
and if you stop I think they can pass
you up do you want to be the best yeah
with the first pick in the 2003 NBA
Draft the Cleveland Cavaliers select
LeBron
[Applause]
they finally showed that the hard work
has finally paid off on with the third
thing
Nuggets select Carmelo and
[Applause]
the game of fun in here
8:56 of the first quarter is when LeBron
James got his first two points it didn't
take him long fellas to get a bunch of
everything else not one side uh you know
once I got my second wind I was I now
they better finish the game he was
everything we expected until you got
look at out to we we worldly
well-rounded
rod quick words for Carmelo and Azir as
they stretched that's a great thing for
the two of them to play together against
each other
Camela plays smooth I'm in control I
think LeBron James you just got a dog
imma see what all the fuss is about
[Music]
sure headlining Wednesday night LeBron
so good start to the season for the
Denver Nuggets with a win on the road
the best play I've played against by far
he's the best player ever opinion when
you compared to other great players or a
good thing uh I can't do number smile
I'm controlling my destiny
I won't people to say that LeBron James
did it his way
don't take the path that I took to get
where I'm at I mean everybody looked at
me and say oh he he lived a great life
he did that she did that and I went
through some some hands I don't forget
him I can't promise a [ __ ] em [ __ ]
snowing you know I can make sure that my
teammates will get better every day
[Music]
[Music]
are you believing this team
hey ain't no question there's LeBron of
a post
chase-down rejections
seconds to go swimmingly recovers fires
[Music]
the answer to the question everybody
wants to know LeBron what's your
decision in this form we'll take my
talents to South Beach and join a Mayan
meet everyone knew the Carmelo wanted to
end up in New York
that's God
putz ahead and the foul
[Applause]
you are obviously very close with
Carmelo Anthony - awesome Brotherhood it
goes beyond basketball
was ever played against
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
with the jump shot
[Applause]
[Music]
the last sentence is the only sentence
it really matters the last sentence says
I'm ready to accept the challenge I'm
coming home
Bauhaus switches out Anthony shoots over
[Music]
get shot
[Music]
[Music]
what's the cabinet up to
famous of the organization this was a
city that I had no problem coming in you
know being a party
[Music]
we've got breaking news LeBron is a
Laker Ron James is a Los Angeles Laker
for what ought to occupy the final act
of his NBA story I love what he did I
love what he's doing
I'm right now not in talking about it mo
they're very quiet is something for a
reason my mother always taught me I'll
talk about it be about it we've always
just talked about our journey while
talking about what CD video Carmelo
Anthony agrees to a non guaranteed
contract with Portland
[Music]
[Applause]
have got that red correlation
[Music]
you try to play the whole game when our
man boy said we gonna win we praying - I
think I'm doing pretty good
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good just gonna get this game you know
going first home game you know but keep
standing all year long man just taking
it one day at a time staying locked in
appreciating this opportunity she's
always been you know that brotherhood
between us the friendship will always be
there the brother would always beat him